I'd like to say that the council has
achieved a broad agreement on the
midterm review revision of the
multi-annual financial framework for
2014 till 2020 we are putting money
where our mouth East financial support
for top priorities will be increased by
over six billion euro in total and I'm
talking about migration including
external border management and root
causes of migration security as well as
growth and jobs including the youth
employment initiative as one of
political priorities we are also making
sure that the EU is better prepared to
meet unexpected needs faster without
changing the MFF expenditure ceilings
how by increasing flexibility of
instruments at our disposal there is a
clear message from the council that we
are committed strongly committed to the
principle of rule of law we are
committed to continuing this dialogue
and we will see what kind of fine-tuning
and adaptation can be made to this
valuable tool that we have at our hand
and that's the rule of law dialogue